America loves Leinenkugel's summer
Shandy it's the perfect summertime drink
but have you ever stopped to wonder what
the heck is a Shandy Shandy is a beer
but it's beer mixed with something a
little extra
that's dick lining kugel this family's
been brewing beer since his great great
grandfather immigrated from Germany so
in 2006 when dick went looking for the
perfect summer beer
he started by asking what do the Germans
drink during the summer
kölsch Berliner Weisse Cave of license
and then he discovered the Shandy in
Germany they were mixing beer with
something extra a tavern owner named
frost Kugler was running out of beer
during a bike race so he mixed it with
lemonade and thirsty cyclists rejoiced
[Music]
inspired dick then turned to brewer
Jacky lawmen I set out to create that
perfect balance of lemonade flavor with
a great beer voila
lining kugel summer Shandy the first
batch was so popular Leinenkugel's ran
out by the fourth of July so the next
time someone asks you what is a Shandy
you can trace its heritage or you can
just tell them it tastes like summer
you